[Music]
what's Jack into Jack is he just turned
two and he is did I don't know if you
ever felt like I was I don't know if
arrogance the right word but I sort of I
was naive enough to think okay it's more
nurture versus nature when you're
raising a child I thought you know boys
are maybe drawn to certain things and
girls are drawn to certain things partly
because as parents that's what we give
them but no turns out at least with my
son trucks trains cars Oh totally that's
what my experience Wow we've tried to do
you'd be very progressive and everything
and my daughter wanted to play with
dolls and my boy has just been shooting
me since he was born you know it's in
there somewhere I don't know why I know
I know so um but I have been encouraging
him with some artwork and and so he does
his his artwork and then he tells Chris
and I what the title of the piece is and
in a week because he doesn't know how to
write yet so he writes the titles of his
pieces yeah he or he comes up with them
and you write them down pretty much and
you brought some of these is that right
yeah and you tell us what the title is
what's the title what's the title of
this one Oh time is a human construct
it not right you came up with that Wow I
can't believe you would show Wow okay
incredible let's see the next one what's
this one at Owl Creek Bridge the
incident at Hope Creek raids 2014 Wow
and Lois this next one right here this
is called because he refused to be a
part of this piece not now not never
defiance
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you